HAVE FIFTY ONE BILL STILL HERE
TODAY ONLY ONE ITEM IS AID TO
PASS THE REMAINING BILLS ARE
ALL ON SUSPENSE. ALL OF THE
AUTHORS HAVE WAIVED
PRESENTATION THE FOLLOWING FIVE
BILLS ARE STILL ON FILE BUT
THEY'LL BE RESCHEDULED FOR NEXT
WEEK AB SIX NINETY FOUR IRWIN
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE AND
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR GRAYSON.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE BLOOM
IN AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY
ROBERT REVISE AS A REMINDER
WE'RE GONNA TRY TO STICK OUR
TESTIMONY TO FISCAL ASPECTS OF
THE BILL. AND WE ARE IS BATES
IS DELAYED TODAY SO SHE SENDS
HER REGRETS BUT WE'RE GONNA
START WE HAVE A QUORUM SOME OF
THE CALL. FOR A ROLL CALL
ESTABLISH A CORE. PORTANTINO
I'M HERE PORTANTINO HERE BATES
BRADFORD DORADO DORADO HERE
HILL HELLO HERE JONES WHITE
HOUSE KEY HERE QUITE CASKEY
HERE. SO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM I
KNOW MISTER JONES IS ON HIS WAY
AS WELL. BUT WE'RE GOING TO GET
WITH IS THAT MISTER JONES LOOK
AT THAT MISTER JONES. HE'S HERE.
MR JONES IS HERE SO WE ARE
GOING TO PROCEED WITH OUR FIRST
AUTHOR OUR ONE AND ONLY
PRESENTATION TO THIS TO YOUR
ONE AND ONLY TODAY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEMOND PLEASE
COME UP. AND TELL US ABOUT AB
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT. YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT HAS BEEN HURTING FOR
POLICY COMMITTEES ADDRESSING
THE NEEDS OF OUR CHILD CARE
WORK FORCE. AS THE BILL HAS
MOVED THROUGH BOTH HOUSES THE
SUPPORT EIGHT RECEIVED A HAS
RECEIVED HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED OF
THOSE WHO CARE FOR EARLY
DISORDERS WITH FISCAL LANGUAGE
INCLUDED IN THE MOST RECENT
BUDGET I AM APPRECIATIVE OF THE
COMMITTEE RECOMMENDING THIS
BILL TO MOVE TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. THIS BILL HAS BEEN
APPROPRIATED SB SEVENTY FIVE
AND WE DO ANTICIPATE SOME
CHAPTER IN AMENDMENTS ON THE
SENATE FLOOR ALL PARTIES ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH COUNSEL.
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IS DIONNE ERIN HERE
REPRESENTING SCA YOU AND ASK ME
THANK YOU MEMBERS TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU HOW
ARE YOU. GOOD MORNING I'M JUST
HERE TO PROTECT PROVIDE AN
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ANYBODY
MIGHT HAVE ON THE ON AIR OKAY
ARE THERE ANY MEMBER ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL OUT THERE.
LINE UP. REALLY ROSENBERGER
WITH SEIU CALIFORNIA AND PROUD
COSPONSOR AND TRANSPORT. THE
MORNING BEVERLY ON BEHALF UT W.
ASKED ME LOCAL THREE NINE
THIRTY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THIS BILL
OR YOUR SUPPORT THANK. MR
MEMBERS COMMITTEE BY NELSON
WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES ALSO PRO COSPONSOR
THIS BILL WOULD URGE THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT. IS THERE
OPPOSITION. SING OPPOSITION IS
FILE GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS JULIE UNDER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
DON'T HAVE A FILE ON THIS
MEASURE OKAY. ARE THERE
QUESTIONS. MR JOBS THANK YOU
THANK CHAIRMAN BUDGET JUST A
QUICK COMMENT I I'M NOT EXACTLY
SURE WHO WOULD. WANT TO ADDRESS
THIS. WE WERE NOTICING THAT IN
THIS WAS PULLED FROM SUSPENSE
LATE ON FRIDAY EVENING. THE
SUSPENSE COUNTERS I GUESS CAN
BE FINALIZED AND ABOUT ELEVEN
DAYS AND THE COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS IS SHOWING THAT EVEN
THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS IS NOT
GOING TO IS NOT GOING TO COVER
THE COSTS OF THE BILL. SO I
JUST ONE AND WHAT THE- WHAT. IS
ON THERE SOMEWHERE I CAN'T WAIT
WITH THE REST THE SUSPENSE
CANICE MY I'LL ANSWER THAT
QUESTION MY AND MY OPINION IS
THAT THE AUTHOR DID A GREAT JOB
WORKING WITH THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. MAKE SURE THAT THE
FUNDING IS IN THE BUDGET AND I
I'M COMFORTABLE KNOWING THAT
THE ALLOCATION IS THERE AND
THAT THE ON GOING COSTS ARE
MINORS OR RIPPLE SO THAT'S WHY
I'M RECOMMENDING IT TO PASS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. SINGER THE
BILL WE HAVE A MOTION WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE A MOTION AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE'LL TAKE THE
VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BRADFORD
DORADO. DORADO AYE HILL. HILL
AYE JONES JON SNOW WHITE HUSKY.
HI BECAUSE HE I. WILL PLACE
THAT ON CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IF YOU. AND THAT IS OUR
ONLY PRESENTATION TODAY WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO THE REST OF OUR
AGENDA WHICH ARE ALL SUSPENSE
ITEM STARTING WITH AB TWENTY
NINE MR HOLDEN ON STATE HIGHWAY
SEVEN TEN IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT. ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION IS THERE FILE YES WE
DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED POSITION
BUT WOULD KNOW THAT CALTRANS
ESTIMATES THE BILL WILL NOT
RESULT IN INCREASED IT COSTS
HOWEVER WE WOULD KNOW THAT THE
BILL MAY LIMIT THE FLEXIBILITY
OF THE STATE IN THE FUTURE IF
IT DECIDES THAT CONSTRUCTING
FREEWAY OR EXPRESSWAY IS IN THE
BEST OPTION. FOR THE SECTION.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY NINE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. AB TWELVE.
TWENTY SIX. STATE HIGHWAY
ASSESSMENTS. SIR ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE TWENTY SIX
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION OF
TWELVE TWENTY SIX SEEING NONE
IS THERE FILE. YES WERE NEUTRAL
ON THIS MEASURE BUT WOULD NOT A
CONCERN ABOUT THE INCREASED
COST TO CALTRANS OF TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO COMPLETE
THE ASSESSMENT. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB
TWELVE TWENTY SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING TO MISTER
O'DONNELL'S BILLS AB FORTY
EIGHT ON PUBLIC AID EDUCATION
FACILITIES BONDS IS THERE
SUPPORT. LINE UP LIZABETH DESK
OF ALL OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING STEVE CREWS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ANDREA BALL ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
EDUCATION COALITION AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND SENATORS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
AIR POCKET AT THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION
STRONG SUPPORT. OLGA SHILOH LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND SUPPORT. THE INPUT DEAR
WITH THE COUNTY SCHOOL
FACILITIES CONSORTIUM AND THE
SCHOOL FACILITY MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING NANCY GENESIS BEEN
ALSO WITH THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE SCHOOL HOUSING AND
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING REBEKAH
CURLY ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACILITY
COALITION IN SUPPORT. HELLO CAN
SWALLOW LARA WAS CONTRA COSTA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
RON RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT. THEIR
OPPOSITION. SINGLE OPPOSITION
AN APPROVED POSITION ON THIS
BUT WE KNOW THAT IF THE TWENTY
TWENTY BOND MEASURES APPROVED
BY THE VOTERS THE STATE WOULD
BE AUTHORIZED ISSUE THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
OBLIGATION BONDS ASSUMING A
THIRTY YEAR REPAYMENT PERIOD
FOR THESE BONDS AND INTEREST
RATES OF 5% AT THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLAR BOND WOULD REQUIRE
ROUGHLY EIGHT HUNDRED FORTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN ANNUAL DEBT
SERVICE AND A COST A TOTAL COST
OF TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
IT'S A TWENTY TWENTY TWO BOND
MEASURES TO PROVIDE THE VOTERS
THE STATE WOULD BE AUTHORIZED
TO ISSUE AN UNKNOWN AMOUNT OF
GENERAL OBLIGATION BONDS
ASSUMING A THIRTY YEAR
REPAYMENT PERIOD FOR THESE 5% A
SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ANNUAL DEBT SERVICE FOUR ONE
BILLION DOLLAR BOND WOULD COST
A TOTAL OF TWO BILLION DOLLARS
AND FOR EXAMPLE A TEN BILLION
DOLLAR BONTA REQUIRE SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN ANNUAL DEBT SERVICE. AND A
TOTAL COST OF TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FORTY EIGHT WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY TO ELECTRICITY RATES IS
THERE SUPPORT. OPPOSITION FILE.
THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO. IS THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
ESTIMATES THIS BILL WERE WILL
RESULT IN AN INCREASE OF ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE QC UTILITIES REIMBURSEMENT
ACCOUNT TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL WE
KNOW THAT ANY REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IS SUBJECT
TO REVIEW AND APPROVAL THROUGH
THE ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS. SHE
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE A. B. FIFTEEN OH
FIVE O'DONNELL AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS. ALL YOU SUPPORTERS
LINE UP ELIZABETH ASK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN
SUPPORT. THE LOWER STRAND
FLORES CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. PROSECUTORS HERE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. A TO A
LARA WAS CONTRA COSTA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
MADELINE CRONENBERG PUBLIC COR
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION IN
SUPPORT. ANDREA BALL ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT. RON WRAPPING BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS A PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
FIFTEEN OH FIVE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. DAVID NEVIN ON
BEHALF OF SANTA ANA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
YOUR OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING
MARTHA ZERO CITY AS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
MUSIC EDUCATORS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND OUR
OPPOSITION IS SPECIFIC TO
SECTION FOUR SEVEN SIX OH FIVE
POINT SIX L. WHICH WOULD ALLOW
TEACHERS WITHOUT CREDENTIALS TO
TEACH SUBJECTS THAT ARE NOT.
CONSIDERED CORE SUBJECTS AND
ALSO IT IS UNCLEAR WHETHER
TEACHERS TORE INSTRUCTING
ENGLISH LEARNER STUDENTS WILL
BE REQUIRED TO POSSESS IO
AUTHORIZATIONS AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THE SECTION NEEDS TO BE
ELIMINATED AND REPLACED WITH
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD REQUIRE ALL
CHARTER SCHOOLS TO HAVE AN
HIGHER CREDENTIALED TEACHERS
FOR ALL SUBJECT AREAS AND FOR
CERTAIN. ALICE LINEUP FISCAL
NOT THE POLICY AND TO ALLOW
TEACHERS FEEL THAT WOULD BE
GREAT OKAY. THANK YOU BYE TO
HAVE THE FISCAL OF THE BILL
DOES IMPOSE ADDITIONAL DUTIES
ON SCHOOL DISTRICTS CHARTER
SCHOOLS COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THAT WE BELIEVE WILL
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND COSTS. AS REFLECTED IN THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CAPULETS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA LANGUAGE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATIONS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR HEALTH PHYSICAL
EDUCATION RECREATION AND DANCE
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
ARTS EDUCATION ALL ASSOCIATE
WITH THE PRIOR COMMENTS WE- ARE
JUST CONCERNED ABOUT THAT ONE
SECTION AND WOULD LIKE TO SEEK
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. JEFF
PRICE WITH THE A PLUS
PERSONALIZED LEARNING NETWORK
ASSOCIATION AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. TONIGHT I
DIDN'T GO TO FINANCIAL.
FINANCIAL FILE NO FILE ANY
QUESTIONS SIGNAL QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B. FIFTEEN
OH FIVE WILL GO THE SUSPENSE
MOVING TO MISTER LOW AB ONE
THIRTY POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
IS OR ANYONE IN SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION IS THERE FILE YES
WERE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT CREATES SIGNIFICANT
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES RELATED TO THE
ESTABLISHMENT AND OPERATION OF
THE COMMISSION A POTENTIALLY AT
A COST OF ABOUT ONE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS BASED ON A
SIMILAR ENTITY THAT OPERATED IN
THE PAST. ONLY THE
ADMINISTRATION RECENTLY
ESTABLISHED A COUNCIL FOR POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION AND THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
INCLUDES FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A LONGITUDINAL
DATA SYSTEM. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
ONE THIRTY WITHOUT A SUSPENSE
AB ONE FORTY TWO GARCIA. ON
BATTERIES. SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FILE. THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL ESTIMATES
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE LEAD ACID BATTERY
CLEANUP FUND ON GOING.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATES ONE TIME
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS OF ONE
HUNDRED TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
SPECIAL FUND. LESLIE ACIDITY OF
ESTIMATES OF THE PROPOSED ONE
DOLLAR INCREASE TO THE
MANUFACTURE FEE WILL INCREASE
REVENUES BY TEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO TWENTY ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY BEGINNING IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. SHE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ONE FORTY TWO WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING THE
MISSILE LOANS OTHER BILLS
STARTING WITH A B. TWO OH NINE
OUTDOOR ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION
SIR SUPPORT. OPPOSITION IS OUR
FILE IN OF PARKS AND RECREATION
ESTIMATES THE COST TO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM TO BE
MINOR OBSERVABLE ABOUT OF ALSO
AB ESTIMATES ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS ARE ESTIMATED TO BE ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS AN ON
GOING AS WELL AS THE GREATER OF
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS OR
5% OF THE AMOUNT APPROPRIATED
FOR GRANTS. WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWO OH NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON A. B. FOUR
OWN NINE ON AGRICULTURAL
CLIMATE ADAPTATION TOOLS AS
THEIR SUPPORT. OPPOSITION FILE
THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH ESTIMATES COSTS OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY TO
SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM IN
ADDITION THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL TO
MAKE AVAILABLE UPON
APPROPRIATION OF TWO TWO
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
FOR THE PROGRAM. THESE FUNDS
WERE NOT PROVIDED IN THE BUDGET
ACT OF TWENTY NINETEEN. SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FOR ONLINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AB FIVE THIRTY NINE CALIFORNIA
FINANCING THEIR SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION. WHEN YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS SOME OUTSELLING
HE'S ON BEHALF OF THE ABOUT
MATTEL OUT POEM OF UPPER LAKE
AND SEVEN OTHER TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL TROUBLE GOVERNMENTS
ARE SEEKING A TROUBLE
GOVERNMENT EXEMPTION FROM THE
BILL THE LANGUAGE HAVE BEEN IN
DISCUSSION FOR THESE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AS FAR AS WE
KNOW THERE IS NO KNOWN
ORGANIZED OPPOSITION TO
LANGUAGE AND NEITHER THE DPO OR
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS IN
OPPOSITION TO. THE LANGUAGE WE
ARE SEEKING. EMILY HUGHES ON
BEHALF OF ON MY LENDERS
ALLIANCE WE ARE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SIR FILE. YES WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
MEASURE BUT WOULD KNOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT A IS AN ABLE AT THIS
TIME TO DETERMINE THE FISCAL
IMPACT AS IT IS IT IS POSSIBLE
THAT MOST COMPANIES WILL REMAIN
LICENSEES WHILE OTHERS MAY
DEPART LEADING TO FEWER
LICENSEES. ANOTHER POSSIBILITY
IS THAT THE MARKET MAY SHIFT IS
LICENSES ARE LICENSED UNDER
MULTIPLE LAWS MAKE IT LIKE
THERE WOULD BE NO CHANGE IN
LICENSE LICENSE NUMBERS AT ALL.
WE WOULD KNOW THAT THERE COULD
BE MORE ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITY
RELATED TO THIS MEASURE. SEEING
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB FACTORED IN I WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB TWELVE FORTY SIX.
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE BASIC
SERVICES SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FILE THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE ESTIMATES COST OF
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE INSURANCE
FUNDED TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER. THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE ESTIMATES MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE COSTS. SHE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION A.
B. TWELVE FORTY SIX FOR THE
SUSPENSE A. B. SIXTEEN EIGHTY.
ON COASTAL ACCESS SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FILE. THE COST OF
ACQUIRING PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE
BEACH AT HOLLISTER RANCHES
UNKNOWN BUT MAYBE IN THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IF THE USE OF EMINENT DOMAIN IS
REQUIRED. ACTIONS REQUIRE A
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE EIGHT
MILES OF THE BEACH AT HOLLISTER
RANCH WILL CREATE SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURE
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO OTHER
APPROPRIATE FUNDS SOURCES WITH
ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
THE COSTS OF THIS MAGNITUDE.
ADDITIONALLY ONGOING OPERATIONS
AND MAINTENANCE COSTS FOR
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE BEACH
HOLLISTER RANCH ARE UNKNOWN.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. SIXTEEN EIGHTY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING TO.
MS RAMOS HER TWO BILLS AB TWO
THIRTEEN ON VEHICLE LICENSING
FEES IS THERE SUPPORT. AS OUR
OPPOSITION SIR FILE YES WERE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE A
BEGINNING IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY THE BILL WILL RESULT IN
ANNUAL REDIRECTION OF
APPROXIMATELY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
FROM THE COUNTY EDUCATIONAL
REVENUE AUGMENTATION FUND. TO
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED FORTY
CITIES OF THIS COST WILL GROW
IN FUTURE YEARS PROPORTIONATE
TO THE INCREASE IN ASSESSED
VALUE IN THE IMPACT TO
JURISDICTIONS RESULTING IN A
CORRESPONDING ANNUAL INCREASE
IN THE STATE'S PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND COSTS.
SHE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWO THIRTEEN
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE A. B.
FIFTEEN TEN. ON STATURE
LIMITATIONS IS THERE SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION. IS THERE FILE
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS MEASURE BUT WE KNOW THAT
THE BILL MAY RESULT IN COST
IMPACTS TO THE TRIAL COURT'S A
TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS BILL
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL CIVIL
ACTIONS YOU COULD ADD TO THE
TRIAL COURTS CASELOAD. WHICH
INCREASES THEIR BACKLOGS AND
COULD CREATE A PRESSURE ON THE
GENERAL FUND HOWEVER WE WOULD
NOTE THAT THECOURTS NOT
TYPICALLY RECEIVE FUNDING ON A
WORKLOAD BASIS AND THEREFORE
UNLESS THIS PARTICULAR CASE
LOAD BECOME SIGNIFICANT AND CAN
BE DOCUMENTED. IT IS LIKELY TO
BE ABSORBED. SEEING THEIR
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION A.
B. FIFTEEN TEN WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE MOVIE TO MISTER
MCCARTY IS TWO BILLS. AB TWO
SEVEN EIGHT CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS IS HER
SUPPORT. OPPOSITION FILE THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
INDICATES THE BILL WILL NOT
RESULT IN ANY IMMEDIATE FISCAL
IMPACTS. BECAUSE IT IS
PERMISSIVE. HOWEVER THE CORN
ROLLS APPLICANTS THAT ARE ON
PAROLE THE COURT DOES KNOW THAT
THERE COULD BE A HIGHER COSTS
TO SUPPORT THESE INDIVIDUALS.
TO ENSURE THEIR MEETING THE
CONDITIONS OF THEIR PAROLE
DURING THE COURSE OF THEIR
ENROLLMENT. SINGLE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FIVE ON PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION. THERE SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION FILE. THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS DOESN'T
ANTICIPATE A FISCAL IMPACT TO
THE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION. WE
WOULD NOTE HOWEVER TO THE TO
THE EXTENT THERE IS AN INCREASE
IN DISCIPLINARY CASES AS A
RESULT OF THIS BILL. THERE
COULD BE ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT
WORKLOAD AND COSTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES COSTS OF SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND FOURTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER. SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE ABOUT A
SUSPENSE. MOVIE NUMBERS TO CHIU
HAS THREE BILLS STARTING WITH
AB THREE HUNDRED ON HATE CRIMES
AND INCIDENT REPORTING IS THEIR
SUPPORT. OPPOSITION IS THERE A
FIVE YES. THE BILL MAY CREATE A
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE ON LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THE
COST OF WHICH ARE UNKNOWN AT
THIS TIME. ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE INDICATES
THE NEED FOR SIX HUNDRED TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN 201-929-0070 THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN 202-021-8009
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND SIX
HUNDRED SIXTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND ON GOING.
WOULD KNOW THAT ANY REQUEST FOR
RESOURCES WILL BE REVIEWED AS
PART OF THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS. LASTLY THERE.
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION INDICATES
UNKNOWN COSTS TO UPDATE ITS
STRATEGIC OFFENDER MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM. SEEING THE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB THREE
HUNDRED WE'RE GONNA SUSPENSE AB
THREE EIGHTEEN ON MEDI CAL
MATERIALS WITH THEIR SUPPORT. I
SAW YOU THERE. A DRY RIVER ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER IN SUPPORT.
PROPOSITION SIR FILE. YES WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE HAS
THE RESULTS IN A GENERAL FUND
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FISCAL PLAN
INCREASE GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURE TO THE EXTENT THE BILL
PLACES ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS
ON COUNTIES FOR PROGRAMS UNDER
TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT.
SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THREE TEAM TO HAVE
A QUESTION. JUST MUMBLING.
CURRENT. WITHOUT OBJECTION AND
ONLY MUMBLING BABY THREE
EIGHTEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING TO AB SIX EIGHTY ON
DISPATCHERS AS THEIR SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION IS THERE FILE.
YES THE COMMISSION ON PIECE OF
FIRST OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING ESTIMATES ONE TIME
COST OF APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
THE STATE PENALTY FUN A TO
DEVELOP THE CURRICULUM AND
TRAIN INSTRUCTORS ON THE NEW
TRAINING CONTENT. ADDITIONALLY
POST ESTIMATES THAT
REIMBURSEMENT COSTS BE TO LOCAL
PUBLIC SAFETY DISPATCHERS FOR
NEWLY CREATED TRAINING COURSE
COULD REACH APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS. IF
ALL DISPATCHERS ATTENDED TO OUR
COURSE AND RECEIVE BACKFILL
CELERY MARIE REIMBURSEMENT. WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THE STATE TALLY
FUND IS CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING
A REGULAR DECLINE IN REVENUES
AND THAT THIS BILL WOULD
CONTINUE TO ADD PRESSURE ON THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE FUND. GO
TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO MISTER
BERMAN HAS TWO BILLS. PARKING
HOMELESS STUDENTS AB THREE OH
TWO IS THERE SUPPORT FOR A BI
THREE OH TWO. MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS LIST BONTA BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA BE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL. PERSONAL GUESTS HERE
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. IS
THERE OPPOSITION. ELEVEN ON
BEHALF OF THE SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY COMMUNICATES DISTRICT WE
HOLD AN OPPOSING LESS AMENDED
BILL. POSITION. HI TO ANYONE
ELSE THERE FILE YES WE'RE POSES
MEASURE HAS A COULD RESULT IN A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE WITH
ANNUAL PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND COST RANGING FROM
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR THE ONE
HUNDRED FOURTEEN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO PROVIDE A
SAFE PARKING PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE ESTIMATES A ONE TIME
COST OF ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO CONDUCT RELEASE
RESULTS FOR STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS SURVEY BY APRIL
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
WITHOUT OBJECTION OR QUESTIONS
AB THREE OH TWO ABOUT A
SUSPENSE AB. FOURTEEN TWENTY
FOUR ON ELECTRICAL VEHICLE
CHARGING STATION IS THEIR
SUPPORT. IS THERE OPPOSITION IS
THERE A FILE YES THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ESTIMATES COST
OF ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE COST
OF IMPLEMENTATION ACCOUNT. A TO
CORPORATE THE BILL'S
REQUIREMENTS. I MISS YOU GUYS.
WE WEREN'T FAST ENOUGH ALL
RIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
MORNING AYE CAPPING LYNCH
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THERE FROM A FISCAL POINT OF
VIEW WE WORKED ON THE ORIGINAL
STATUTE IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN WAS CENTER CORBETT
THAT JUST WENT THROUGH A FORMAL
RULE MAKING IT THE AIRBOARD
THIS BILL IS ON NECESSARY THEY
DID DEAL WITH THE RETROFIT
ISSUE WHICH WAS THE COST ISSUE
AT THE A RP. AND THEY PREDICT
FLEXIBILITY FOR NEW TECHNOLOGY
SHOULD IT OCCUR TO REOPEN THE
REGULATIONS THIS WOULD ON DO
ALL THAT IT WENT ON TO THE
STATUTE AND IT WOULD COST ABOUT
CARP TO HAVE TO GO BACK TO
ANOTHER FORMAL RULE MAKING AND
DELAY FURTHER IMPLEMENTATION OF
OPEN ACCESS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
STAND THEM BLACK REPRESENTING
SIEMENS ONE WORLD SARS
ENGINEERING COMPANIES WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS PRIMARILY
BECAUSE IT TAKES MONIES FROM
THE STATE AND NOW SHIFTING FOR
PRIVATE PURPOSE WITHOUT ANY
OVERSIGHT FROM AGENCIES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CAN MEMBERS
NIKITA CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL TO
REGRETTABLY OPPOSED TO ME LIKE
TO LINE OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE
OF TALKING AMERICA THINKING.
SHOULD. THE ENTERPRISE ANY
QUESTIONS SINGLE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB THREE EIGHTY SIX
EDUARDO GARCIA ON FARMWORKERS
IS THEIR SUPPORT. IS THERE
OPPOSITION IS THERE FILE YES TO
THE EXTENT FUNDING IS
APPROPRIATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
FOR THIS PROGRAM THE DEPARTMENT
OF COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES ON GOING
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. ADDITIONALLY WITH A
NOTE THAT THIS BILL DOESN'T
SPECIFY A FUNDING SOURCE OR
TOTAL FUNDING AMOUNT FOR THE
PROGRAM. ASSUMING THIS BILL
SEEKS TO MAKE THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM FARM
WORKER HOUSING COMPONENTS
PERMANENT. AT CURRENT FUNDING
LEVELS WE ESTIMATE THAT THE
BILL'S ANNUAL GRANT AWARD COSTS
WOULD BE APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS. SHE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
THREE EIGHTY SIX FOR THE LITTLE
SUSPENSE. AB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
MR GABRIEL ON ADVERSE DRUG
EVENTS AND PRESCRIPTIONS IS
THEIR SUPPORT. SIR OPPOSITION
IS THERE FILE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS INDICATES THAT
ANY COSTS FROM THIS BILL ARE
WOULD BE MINOR NOSE OR MOBILE
TO THE MEDICAL BOARD AND THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY OF WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT BY SPECIFYING THAT
THE TASK FORCE ME RECEIVE
FUNDING PURSUANT TO AN
APPROPRIATION THIS BILL CREATES
A GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURE.
AND EXPECTATION FOR THE STATE
TO FUND THE TASK FORCE. SING
THE QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. MR GLORIA. SAN
DIEGO AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICTS AB FOR TWENTY THREE
SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION FILE YES
WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURES
TO CREATE THE PRESIDENT FOR THE
STATE TO STIPULATE COUNTY OR
DISTRICT BOARD MEMBERSHIP ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS. THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ESTIMATES COSTS
OF ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL FUND TO CONDUCT THE
REQUIRED AUDIT OF THE
DESTRUCTION PROVIDE LONG TERM
OVERSIGHT ACTIVITIES
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THIS BILL COULD CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE.
SEEING THE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A BEFORE TWENTY THREE
WE'RE GOING TO SUSPEND SAY
BEFORE ANYONE MOVING TO MR
STONE HAS THREE BILLS. AB FOR
EIGHTY NINE IS YOUR SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION SIR FILE YES WERE
NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE WOULD
KNOW THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES INDICATES.
MINOR OBSERVABLE COSTS. SEEING
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB FORTY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. AB FIVE FIVE TWO ONE
COASTAL RESOURCES IS THERE
SUPPORT. MR OPPOSITION JUST
WONDERING ALL RIGHT OKAY NO
FILE YES WE DON'T HAVE AN A
POSITION ON THIS BILL THIS TIME
BUT WE KNOW THAT THIS BILL
TAKES A PORTION OF EXISTING
THAILAND'S REVENUE APPROXIMATE
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY FROM THE GENERAL FUND
BASED ON THE AVERAGE OF THE
LAST THREE YEARS REVENUES AND
DEDICATED TO A FUNDS AVAILABLE
UPON APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO VARIOUS ENTITIES
FOR ACTIVITIES ON SEA LEVEL
RISE AND COASTAL ADAPTATION
PROGRAMS. SEEING THE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FIVE FIVE
TWO A SUSPENSE. AB TWELVE
SEVENTY STONE ON FALSE CLAIMS.
SIR SUPPORT THEIR OPPOSITION IS
THERE FILE. YES WE ARE NEUTRAL
ON THIS BILL BUT WITH NO
CONCERNS AT THE INCREASED COST
TO THE FALSE CLAIMS ACT FUND
COULD CREATE GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURE TO BACK FILL THE FUND.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES OF COST OF EIGHT
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE FUND IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND ON GOING
TO INVESTIGATE VIOLATIONS AND
BRING CIVIL ACTIONS AGAINST
VIOLATORS. RELATED TO THE
EXPANSION OF THE ACT. SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWELVE SEVENTY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING TO MISTER
KALRA HAS ONE BILL AB FIVE
SEVENTY TWO ONE DEFORESTATION
IS THEIR SUPPORT. HELLO
NICHOLAS SECOND NOW
REPRESENTING SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION PROD CO SPONSORS
THE BILL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SO THE NOT NOT
LIKE HAS PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON
BEHALF OF ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE
FUND IN SUPPORT. IS THERE
OPPOSITION. IS FILE. YES THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
ESTIMATES ONE TIME COST OF
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO MEET THE BILL'S REQUIREMENTS
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IDENTIFIED COSTS AND
THE THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
ASSOCIATED WITH UPDATING THE
STATE'S MASTER LAW ENFORCEMENT
CO TABLES WE KNOW THAT BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WILL INCUR UNKNOWN COSTS
RELATED TO RECEIVING AN
INVESTIGATING REPORTS OF
VIOLATIONS OF THIS BILL FROM ST
ENTITIES. ADDITIONALLY THE
OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS WILL OCCUR WORKLOAD
RELATED COSTS BECAUSE THE BILL
ALLOWS CONTRACTORS TO REQUEST A
HEARING BEFORE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE PRIOR
TO BEING SANCTIONED FOR
VIOLATING THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THIS BILL. SEE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE FIVE
SEVENTY TWO WILL GO TO. SAYS
SPENCE AB SEVEN NINETEEN RUBIO.
CROCODILES AND ALLIGATORS. I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT. IS
THERE SUPPORT. IS THERE
OPPOSITION. YEAH. GOING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JENNIFER
FEARING HERE ON BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND ALSO
CONVEYING THE OPPOSITION OF
CLEAN WATER ACTION THIS IS A
POOR POLICY THAT IMPOSE A
SIGNIFICANT COSTS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AT A TIME WHEN THEY ARE
UNDERGOING A SERVICE BASED
BUDGET REVIEW TO ANALYZE ALL
THE WAYS IN WHICH THEY ARE
LIKELY UNDERFUNDED TO DELIVER
ON THE MISSION AND GIVEN THAT
THERE IS NO SUCH TRACK AND
TRACE SYSTEM AS DESCRIBED IN
THE BILL AND NO DISCERNIBLE
EFFORT BY. THE INDUSTRY TO
CREATE IT WE THINK THESE COSTS
ARE WHOLLY UNJUSTIFIED DUE TO
HOLD THE BILL. THANK YOU TURN
BIRDS NIKITA CREDIT WITH A
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL ALSO OPPOSE AND ALSO
REGISTERING OPPOSITION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS THINKING.
NICHOLAS SOCKET SOCIAL
COMPASSION LEGISLATION THIS ONE
MENTIONED THAT THE NEW
AMENDMENTS TALKED ABOUT. HUMANE
TREATMENT OF THE ANIMALS WE'RE
NOT SURE HOW EXACTLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH WILDLIFE IS
BOTH IMPLEMENT THAT FINALLY PUT.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN NORWOOD
ON BEHALF OF BOEING INGELHEIM
OUR SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. SO THE MATTER THAT MY
HUSBAND LOOK AFFAIRS HERE
BEHALF OF ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE
FUND IN OPPOSITION. IS THERE
FOR. AS WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION AT THIS TIME BUT WE
KNOW THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE ALTHOUGH
UNABLE TO PROVIDE AN UPDATED
FISCAL ESTIMATE BASED ON THE
MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS WE WERE
NOTE THAT WILL LIKELY HAVE
SIGNIFICANT COST TO ENGAGE IN
THE PROCESS IS SPECIFIED IN THE
BILL TO DETERMINE THE TRACKING
TECHNOLOGY AND PROCESSES NEEDED
TO IDENTIFY THE ORIGIN OF A
CROCODILE OR ALLIGATOR. HIDE
AND ITS MANNER OF TREATMENT
SLAUGHTER IN ADDITION THERE
WILL BE COST UPDATE AND
IMPLEMENT REGULATIONS RELATED.
TO THE TRADE. FINALLY ARE. WE
ESTIMATE PRELIMINARILY THE
ANNUAL COST TO BE AT LEAST ONE
MILLION DOLLARS BUT THIS
ESTIMATE IS SUBJECT TO FURTHER
REFINEMENT. ADDITIONALLY THE
PARTMINER JUSTICE ESTIMATES
COST OF EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN THE CURRENT YEAR ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND AS WELL
AS ON GOING FROM THE GENERAL
FUND IN THE LEGAL SERVICES
REVOLVING FUND. TO HANDLE
REFERRALS FROM FISH AND
WILDLIFE A AND A LITTLE
LITIGATE MATTERS ARISING FROM
THIS BILL. SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB SEVEN
NINETEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
AB EIGHT EIGHT ONE MISTER BLOOM
ON EIGHTY. IS THERE SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS LOSE
MANTE WITH CALIFORNIAN BE HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB A ONE.
GOOD MORNING SO THE NIGHT AND I
HEAR A BEHALF OF THE THREE P.
IS SB AT HOME AND PH AND
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. DAVID ON
BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA HOUSING
ADVOCACY COALITION IN SUPPORT.
PROSECUTORS HERE BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA IN SUPPORT.
SIR ANY OPPOSITION. SIR FILE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
COSTS OF NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE FIRST YEAR AND
EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON GOING TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ANY REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT WILL
BE SUBJECT TO REVIEW AND
APPROVAL. TO THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS. SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB EIGHT
EIGHT ONE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
MOVIE TO MISTER GIBSON HAS TWO
BILLS. NINE A ONE JUVENILES SIR
SUPPORT ON AB NINE A ONE. STOP
POSITION AB NINE A ONE THEIR
FILE ON AB ONE NINE A ONE. AT
THIS BILL COULD RESULT IN A
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE BY
REQUIRING LOCAL AGENCIES
PROVIDE REFERRALS TO COMMUNITY
BASED PROGRAMS. AND BY
REQUIRING PROBATION OFFICERS TO
OFFER SERVICES WHEN COMMUNITY
BASED DIVERSION ORGANIZATIONS
ARE UNAVAILABLE TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES. OF THE MAGNITUDE OF
THESE COST IS UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL COULD
RESULT IN MINOR PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES FOR LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. TO PROVIDE TRAINING
TO SCHOOL ATTENDANCE REVIEW
BOARDS ON THE NEWER FILE
PRACTICES. SEE NO QUESTIONS
ABOUT OBJECTION AB NINE ONE
WE'RE GOING TO SUSPEND SAY BE
THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION IS THEIR SUPPORT.
THEIR OPPOSITION. MR MEMBERS
BRIAN WHITE HERE WE HAVE THE
PACIFIC MERGING SHIP IN
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY WE ARE
POLLS BUILT ON FISCAL AND
POLICY GROUNDS WE BELIEVE THIS
BILLS UNNECESSARY THE
LEGISLATURE IS ALREADY MANDATED
STATE LAWS TO DEAL WITH
ADDRESSING AUTOMATION STUDIES
INCLUDING AB THREE NINE EIGHT
AS WELL AS THE GOVERNOR HAS
ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
LOOK AT THE FUTURE WORK WE
THINK THIS BILL IS ON THE
SYRIAN. SHOULD AUSTELL DISPENSE
THANK. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ALICE KESSLER ON BEHALF
OF THE PACIFIC MARITIME
ASSOCIATION. ALSO IN OPPOSITION
FOR THE REASONS STATED
PREVIOUSLY THANK YOU. SIR FIVE
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
INDICATES UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND COSTS TO CONVENE AND
FACILITIES STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT MEETINGS. AND RE
DIRECT STAFF TIME AND WORKLOAD
TO DEVELOP AND COMPLETE THE TO
LEGISLATIVE REPORTS REQUIRED IN
THE BILL. AND OF THOSE BILL
DOESN'T DIRECTLY CREATE ANY
ADDITIONAL STATE COSTS BECAUSE
IT MAKES CONVENING AND
FACILITATING THE MEETINGS
CONTINGENT UPON THE
AVAILABILITY OF FUNDS WE KNOW
THAT IT DOES CREATE A GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURE IF OTHER
RESOURCES ARE NOT IDENTIFIED.
SHE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
ONE. WE GOT A SUSPENSE MOVING
TO. MISS BONNER **** BATH LOCAL
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS AB NINE
THIRTY ONE. SIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FILE THE BILL'S
POTENTIAL IMPACT ON THE GENERAL
FUND IS ON QUANTIFIABLE AT THIS
TIME BUT WE BELIEVE IT COULD BE
SIGNIFICANT MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED OF CALIFORNIA'S FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY CITIES HAVE
FIFTY THOUSAND OR MORE
RESIDENTS IF THESE CITIES
AVERAGE A MINIMUM OF A ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ONGOING
COMPLIANCE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS MEASURE YOU KNOW
GENERAL FUND EXPOSURE WOULD BE
MORE THAN TWO ONE. THOUSAND
DOLLARS. SHE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT A. NINE THIRTY ONE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE A. B. TEN THIRTY
SIX AYE YE ARE CURRY ELECTION
CIVIC OUT READ. IS THERE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FILE.
BECAUSE IT IS UNCLEAR WHETHER
HELP AMERICA VOTE ACT FUNDING
CAN BE USED FOR THE PURPOSES
RELATED TO THIS BILL THIS BILL
COULD RESULT IN GENERAL FUND
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS FOR THE SECRETARY OF
STATE TO FUND AND ADMINISTER
THE GRANTS ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL MAY CREATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE BY
REQUIRING THE SECRETARY OF
STATE TO UPDATE ITS REGULATIONS
AND REQUIRING THOSE REGULATIONS
TO REQUIRE EACH COUNTY TO
PERIODICALLY UPDATE. IT'S VOTER
REGISTRATION PROGRAMS. SEEING
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
MAYBE TEN THIRTY SIX WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE MISTER TING. HAS TWO
BILLS AB TEN FORTY SIX CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM. THEIR
SUPPORT. PROSECUTORS HERE ON
BEHALF ADVANCE ENERGY ECONOMY
IN SUPPORT. SIR OPPOSITION SIR
FILE. YES THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD ESTIMATES COSTS OF ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND ON GOING AS WELL
AS NINE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME CONTRACT
COSTS TO DEVELOP AT THE
SPECIFIED FUNDING PLANNED AND
FORECAST ANNUAL ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE SALES TO TWENTY THIRTY.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
A. B. TEN FORTY SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION
MOVING TO MISS FRIEDMAN HAS ONE
TWO THREE FOUR BILLS STARTING
WITH. THAT I MISS WITH TENS OF
SIX SO I MISSED TEN SEVENTY SIX
LOOK AT THAT. AB TEN SEVENTY
SIX MISTER TING ON CRIMINAL
RECORDS. IS THERE SUPPORT. SIR
OPPOSITION. NO SUPPORT NO
OPPOSITION JUST LOTS OF CHAIR
MOVING. OKAY. HOW TO CONFUSE
THE CHAIR MOVE YOUR CHAIR. IS
THERE FILE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES COSTS OF ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY SEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND NINE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AS WELL AS NINE MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE EIGHT POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND EIGHT POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE AN ON
GOING FOR THE WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS MEASURE.
ADDITIONALLY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL ESTIMATES COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO TEN MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. DUE TO THE
INCREASED WORKLOAD FOR COURTS.
FINALLY THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
ESTIMATES THE BILL WILL REDUCE
COURT REVENUES BETWEEN TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO SIXTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TEN
SEVENTY SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
NOW MOVING TO MS FRIEDMAN'S
BILL STARTING WITH AB ELEVEN
ELEVEN. ON OUTDOOR RECREATION
SIR SUPPORT. IT'S A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M ST LOUIS
WITHOUT THEIR INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR A. B. ELEVEN ELEVEN
WITH CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR
RECREATION. PARTNERSHIP WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS JENNIFER HEWLETT.
REPRESENTING PATAGONIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
WITH A THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
AMBER MIXER ON BEHALF OF THE
ARI I CO OP IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN ELEVEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S THEIR
CAMPBELL AND I WORK AT CAL BACK
PRODUCTS AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN ELEVEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR KATIE
HAWKINS FROM OUTER ALLIANCE
HAVE REPRESENT TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS AND WE
ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN ELEVEN. MY DILLON WITH
CALIFORNIA SKI INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. MR
MEMBERS MARK SMITH ON BEHALF OF
SEVERAL DIFFERENT ENTITIES NOT
IN SUPPORT NOT IN OPPOSITION
BUT TWO COMMENTS RELATED TO THE
FISCAL ANALYSIS THE FIRST IS
THAT STAFF POINTS OUT THE
PRIVATE CONTRIBUTIONS COULD
HELP OFFSET OFFSET THE COST TO
THE STATE WE SUGGEST AN
AMENDMENT TO THE DEFINITION OF
OUTDOOR RECREATION THAT
CLARIFIES IT OUTDOOR RECREATION
INCLUDES BOTH MOTORIZED AND NON
MOTORIZED RECREATION WE THINK
THAT THAT WOULD ENCOURAGE.
PARTNERS TO STEP UP TO THE
TABLE KNOWING THAT THEY ARE
INCLUDED IN THE SCOPE OF THIS
BILL AND PERHAPS PROVIDE SOME
PRIVATE CONTRIBUTIONS SECOND
THERE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE OF
W'S ENGAGEMENT IN THIS BILL AND
WHILE WE THINK THAT THEY WOULD
BE A GOOD GROUP TO INCLUDE
PERHAPS WE CAN INCLUDE THE
DIVISION OF BOATING AND
WATERWAYS THEY WERE UNTIL
RECENTLY A STANDALONE STATE
ENTITY RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL OF
THE STATE'S WATERWAYS. WE HAVE
MORE REGISTERED BOATS IN
CALIFORNIA THAN ANY OTHER STATE
SECOND ONLY TO FLORIDA TO HUGE
PART OF OUR OUTDOOR RECREATION
ECONOMY IN THE DIVISION OF
BOATING AND WATERWAYS IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR MANAGING BOTH
THOSE MOTORIZED A NON MOTORIZED
OPPORTUNITIES THERE IS A
PROVISION IN THE BILL TO
INCLUDE A REPRESENTATIVE FROM
STATE PARKS BUT WE THINK YOU
SHOULD INCLUDE TO. SPECIFY THAT
ONE BE A STATE EMPLOYEE OF THE
DIVISION OF BOATING AND
WATERWAYS WANT TO CLARIFY NOT
THE COMMISSION BUT ACTUAL
EMPLOYEE OF THE DIVISION ABOUT
IT WATER WAYS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. TURN MEMBERS JERRY DOES
MENTAL BEHALF FOR RECREATIONAL
BOATERS A CALIFORNIA NO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL PROVIDED
THAT THERE ARE IT IS UNDERSTOOD
THAT THE PROGRAM WILL NOT TO
CREATE FUNDING PRESSURES ON IT
ON EXISTING PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT ARE FINANCED BY
RECREATIONAL BOATERS WATER
WHICH IS THE DIVISION OF
PUTTING A WATER WAYS A WHICH IS
NOT GENERAL FUND RELIANT JUST
PUTTING GAS TAX DOLLARS IN FEES
AND RETURNS ON LOANS. AND WE
SUPPORT THE ADDITION OF DB W.
THE DIVISION VOTER WATER WAY TO
THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE WELL
THERE ARE THREE MILLION
RECREATIONAL BOATERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IT'S A GOODS A
CONSTITUENCY THAT A CHURCH IS
OUT OR RECREATION I THINK WE
SHOULD HAVE A PLACE AT THE
TABLE. THANK YOU. MORNING CAPPY
ONE REPRESENTING THE OFF ROAD
VEHICLE LEGISLATIVE COALITION
AND WE CONCUR WITH THE
MOTORIZED A NON MOTORIZED AND
WE ARE TECHNICALLY UNDER PARKS
ALSO SO HAVE SOME
REPRESENTATION THERE AND
BOATING AND OFFER A CHAIR OF
THE BOARD MEMBERS ALSO SO WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME LANGUAGE
THAT KIND OF FUN. INCORPORATES
ALL THAT THANK YOU. THEREFORE
HAVE. YES THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION
ANTICIPATES IT WILL LIKELY BE
SELECTED TO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL'S PROVISIONS A GIVEN
THEIR EXISTING ROLE IN OUTDOOR
RECREATION AN ESTIMATES FIRST
YEAR COST OF THREE HUNDRED TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
WITH AN ONGOING ANNUAL COST O
TWO HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLARS HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THAT
THE PARKS'S ESTIMATE MAYBE LOW.
GIVEN THE SCOPE OF THE
ACTIVITIES PROPOSED IN THE BILL.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT A SECTIONING.
THE BILL ESTABLISHES THE
CALIFORNIA'S SUSTAINABLE
OUTDOOR RECREATION ACCOUNT.
FROM WHICH THE OFFICE IS TO
EXPAND FUNDS HOWEVER THE BILL
FAILED TO IDETIFY DEDICATED
FUND SOURCE. AND WE KNOW
CONCERNED THAT IS UNCERTAIN
WHETHER SIGNIFICANT FUNDING
WILLBE AVAILABLE FOR THE
ACCOUNT. AS IT MAY BE COMPETING
WITH EXISTING OUTDOOR
RECREATIONAL PROGRAM FUNDING.
HE JONES HAVE A QUESTIONNAIRE.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE PROPONENTS OF THE
BILL FOR COMING UP TODAY AND
SHARING THEIR THOUGHTS ON THE
BILL I KNOW THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY DILIGENTLY ON THIS
AND GETTING BI PARTISAN SUPPORT
ON THE BILL. SO THEY'VE DONE A
GOOD JOB ON THAT I ALSO AM
INTRIGUED BY THE COMMENTS
REGARDING THE- SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU KNOW MAYBE
THOSE ARE SOMETHING THAT WE
TAKE A LOOK AT. BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS I'M OPEN IT WHEN IT
COMES UP AT SAYS AT THE
SUSPENSE TIME AT THE- COMMITTEE
WILL MOVE IT FORWARD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES. A
SINGLE THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
ELEVEN ELEVEN WE GO TO
SUSPENSE. AB ELEVEN FORTY TWO
ON REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLANS. SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE A SOLUTION
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE IN OUR FOR OUR
LOOK REGIONAL AND A CITY WIDE
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
SERVICES THAT DATA THAT WOULD
BE PROVIDED BY THIS MEASURE IS
CRITICAL TO UNDERSTANDING WHAT
IS GOING ON IN OUR CITIES IN
TERMS OF THE- NUMBERS OF TNC
THAT ARE ON OUR CITY STREETS
AND ROADS SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. AND HOPE THIS GETS OFF
SUSPENSE THANK YOU. OPPOSITION
FINANCE THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ANTICIPATES A FISCAL
IMPACT OF ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING
FROM THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TRANSPORTATION
REIMBURSEMENT ACCOUNT RELATED
TO THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL.
CHINO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ELEVEN FORTY TWO A
SUSPENSE MOVING TO A. B. ELEVEN
FORTY FOUR ON COMMUNITY ENERGY
STORAGE SYSTEMS. SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION ESTIMATES
MINOR OBSERVABLE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS MEASURE.
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE SELF
GENERATION INCENTIVE PROGRAM
FUNDS THAT WILL BE REALLOCATED
BY THIS BILL ARE FROM CONSUMER
FEES THAT ARE HELD IN
DISTRIBUTED DISTRIBUTED PER P.
C. DIRECTION BY THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES AND A THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR I DO NOT GO
TO THE STATE BUDGET. SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR WE'RE GONNA
SUSPENSE AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN ON
FIRE PREVENTION DEFENSIBLE
SPACE SUPPORT. YOUR COVERAGE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS IN SUPPORT. GERMAN
OF LIBERTY MUTUAL WE'RE ALSO
SUPPORT THANK YOU. OPPOSITION
SIR OF FILE YES CAL FIRE WAS
NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE AN UPDATED
FISCAL FOR THIS BILL BASED ON
THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS
HOWEVER WE WOULD KNOW THAT
ALTHOUGH THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
WILL WILL REDUCE COSTS WE
ESTIMATE THE BILL WILL STILL
RESULT IN ONE TIME AND ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
ADDITIONALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
INDICATES THE BILL WILL RESULT
IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND COSTS
OF ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD
NOTE THAT THIS BILL COULD
RESIST COULD RESULT IN A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE. CHECK THE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION A.
B. FIFTEEN SIXTEEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE MISTER WOOD. MEDI CAL WAS
THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION FILE
YES WERE POSES MEASURE AS IT
RESULT IN UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND COSTS AND CERTAIN
PROVISIONS MAY BE DUPLICATIVE
OF FEDERAL LAW UNDER THE
MEDICAID MANAGED CARE FINAL
RULE. SIGNAL QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE AGO TO SUSPENSE. MISTER
JONES SAWYER HAS A. B. TWELVE
NINETEEN IS THERE SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION FILE THIS BILL TO
CREATE NEW COSTS IN THE LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
ADDITIONALLY IF THE COMMISSION
ON STATE MANDATES DETERMINES
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL
CREATE A SUCH A MANDATE OF THIS
BILL WOULD CREATE A COST
PRESSURE TO INCREASE THE
MANDATE BLOCK GRANT FUNDING FOR
ELLIE ACE. CHINO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWELVE
NINETEEN WITH A SUSPENSE.
MOVING TO GONZALEZ TWELVE
NINETY SIX TAX RECOVERY SIR
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWELVE NINETY
SIX OPPOSITION. IS THERE A FILE.
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES OF THE COST OF SIX
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY NINE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ELEVEN POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
AND FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AN ON GOING. THE PART OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATES COST OF SIXTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY. SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. ONE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. ONE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AND
ONE POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
ON GOING. OF PETITION THE
ACIDITY OF ESTIMATES INCREASED
RECOVERED REVENUES IN THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A STARTING
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES COST OF
TWO POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND TO TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY AND ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND ON GOING.
FOR INVESTIGATORS AND
ASSOCIATED COSTS. THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD ESTIMATES COST OF
FOREIGN AND SIXTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. EIGHT
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. AND NINE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING FOR ADDITIONAL
INVESTIGATIVE STAFF AND RELATED
TRAVEL COSTS FINALLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
ESTIMATES COSTS OF TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
TO TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY.
SIXTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
FORTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY . IN THE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWELVE
NINETY SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX. A VOICE
OVER INTERNET PROTOCOL IS THEIR
SUPPORT. ALICIA PRIEGO ON
BEHALF OF VERIZON SUPPORT.
THEIR OPPOSITION. THIRTY IS
SANDERS REPRESENTING THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU. FILL THE A SOLUTION
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR THE COUNTIES OF
MENDOCINO AND HUMBOLDT AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA ALL IN OPPOSITION. IS
THERE FILE. IS THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION ESTIMATES
COSTS OF THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
QC UTILITIES REIMBURSEMENT
ACCOUNT FOR IDENTIFYING AND
ADVOCATING FOR SAFETY RELATED
ISSUES FROM VOICE OVER INTERNET
PROTOCOL SERVICES AND FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE. ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE INDICATES
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE INFERENCE UNFAIR
COMPETITION LAW FUND IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWO POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
FOR ENFORCEMENT OF THE SERVICE
COMPLAINTS. CHINO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX VOTER
SUSPENSE MS WEBER HAS A. B.
FOURTEEN SIXTY ON ETHNIC
STUDIES IS THEIR SUPPORT. MR
TURN MEMBER SYLVIA SOLUTION ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION WE ARE THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL WE THINK
THIS IS ADDRESSES A CRITICAL
SOCIAL AND RACIAL JUSTICE ISSUE
IN REGARDS TO THE COST OF THE
BILL. THERE IS CURRENTLY TWENTY
FIVE MILLION IN FUNDING FROM
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET AND THIRTY FIVE
MILLION AN ONGOING FUNDING TO
HIRE TENURE TRACK FACULTY WHICH
WE BELIEVE COULD BE USED. FOR
THIS UP NEW COURSE SO WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. IS
THERE OPPOSITION. MARY MORE OIL
WITH THE CSU AND WE'RE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING DAVE SPEAK
I'M A PROFESSOR OF POLITICAL
SCIENCE AT CAL POLY POMONA AND
CHAIR OF FISCAL AND
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS FOR THE A
CSU THE ACADEMIC SENATE FOR
THIS ISSUE. WHICH IS THE ONLY
BODY. AUTHORIZED TO SPEAK FOR
THE FACULTY OF THE TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES OF THE CSU IN MATTERS
OF CURRICULUM WHICH THIS BILL
CONCERNS. THE COSTS OF THE
LEGISLATION ARE SIGNIFICANT
INCLUDING RECURRING COSTS OF
TEN TO FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. AND SIGNIFICANTLY A
ONE TIME COST OF ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS AS A HUNDRED
AND TWELVE THOUSAND TRANSFER
CREMINS WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE REVIEWED FOR COMPLIANCE
WITH THE NEW REQUIREMENT. THESE
COSTS ARE NOT COVERED BY THE
STATE OR COULD THEY BE
SUPPORTED BY ONE TIME RESERVE
SUPPORT INCREASING TUITION. AND
THAT'S NOT COUNTING THE COST OF
DISLOCATION FOR THE DEPARTMENTS
AND AFFILIATED PERSONAL NOT
INCLUDED IN THE BILL. TO THE
REALLOCATION OF UNITS INTO ONLY
THE FOR SPECIFIED AREAS TO FIND
IN THE LEGISLATION. THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD BE THE ONLY
PIECE OF HIGHER EDUCATION
CURRICULUM IN CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORY MANDATED BY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. THAT'S A DANGEROUS
IN THE SLIPPERY SLOPE SITTING
HERE TODAY WE CANNOT TELL PUT
THE CHANGING TIDES OF POLITICS
WILL DEMAND WITH EQUAL
EARNESTNESS NEXT TIME. THE A
CSU IS SUPPOSED TO THE BILL.
CURRENT JUST IN TERMS OF. IN
CALCULATING THE COST AND I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT COMES WITH
YOU IS THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
IF NOT EVERY CAMPUS ALREADY
PROVIDES ETHNIC STUDIES DOES
THAT FIT IN SOMEWHERE IN TERMS
OF COST OR SAVINGS. YES I
SUSPECT THAT THAT SHOWS UP IN
THE FINANCE FILE BUT YOU THAT
WAS TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT IN THE
CHANCES OFFICE ESTIMATION OF
BETWEEN TEN AND FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS ONE POINT COSTS. YOU
WANT TO ASK ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. I'M SURE MERRY MORE
WITH THE CSU YET THERE MANY OF
OUR CAMP CAMPUSES ALREADY DO
OFFERED THOSE CORE COURSES. BUT
IT WOULD BE A MATTER OF WE'D
HAVE TO OFFER THEM TO EVERY
SINGLE STUDENT. AND SO THAT
WOULD YOU KNOW RAISE THE NUMBER
OF COURSE IS BEING. OFFERED IN
THE FACULTY HIRED. CHAU FROM
ELECTED TO A REQUIREMENT.
EXACTLY. THANK YOU THE DENTURE
QUESTION. SEVEN THANK IS THERE
FIVE YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE AS A COULD CREATE ON
GOING GENERAL FUND COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY SIXTEEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND COSTS OF ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE CSU TO DEVELOP THE REQUIRED
COURSES INCREASES HIRING ETHNIC
STUDIES FACULTY A AND SUPPORT
THE ASSOCIATED MANAGE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. WE WOULD
ALSO NOTE THIS BILL COULD
CREATE UNKNOWN PROPOSITION
NINETY GENERAL FUND COSTS FOR
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
REVISE ITS EXISTING ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER PATHWAYS
AND EXPAND THEIR OFFERING OF
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES TO
PROSPECTIVE TRANSFER STUDENTS
IF THE REQUIRED COURSES WERE TO
BE CONSIDERED A LOWER DIVISION
COURSE REQUIREMENT. FINALLY WE
NOTE THAT THE CONTENT OF THIS
YEAR'S USE GENERAL EDUCATION
FRAMEWORK WE BELIEVE IS MORE
APPROPRIATELY DETERMINED BY THE
COLLECTIVE EFFORTS OF THE CSU
BOARD OF TRUSTEES A CAMPUS
LEADERS ADMINISTRATORS AND
FACULTY. WITHOUT A FINANCIAL
ISSUE THAT YOU JUST THE LAST
COMMENT YOU MADE. NO THAT'S
JUST ONE OF OUR POINTS OF
OPPOSITION. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT SIGNAL THE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO BY MR CHU
ON TENNESSEE BRENT CAPS.
SUPPORT MINE UP. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS BRIAN GUST ON
BEHALF OF ACE AS WELL AS THE
NUMBER OF GROUPS WHO ARE CO
SPONSORING THIS MEASURE
INCLUDING PICO WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY PUBLIC
ADVOCATES POLICY LINK AND TECH
EQUITY COLLABORATIVE. URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS MEASURE WHICH
WILL PROVIDE A CRITICAL
PROTECTIONS FOR THE SEVENTEEN
MILLION RENTERS IN CALIFORNIA
WHO ARE CURRENTLY STRUGGLING.
TO MAKE ENDS MEET THE BENEFITS
OF THIS BILL WILL HELP EXPAND
OUR ECONOMY BY PROTECTING THE
RENTER'S ENSURING THAT MORE
MONEY IN THEIR POCKETS TO MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS AND FOR THAT
WE WOULD URGE. THAT THIS BILL
MOVE OFF OF SUSPENSE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS LUIS
BRONTE WITH CALIFORNIA BE
ALIGNING OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS. GOOD MORNING
CHEN MEMBERS AS A MATTER NOT
LIKE HAS PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE
BEHALF OF THE THREE PIECE
COALITION SB AT HOME AND PH AND
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
EAST BAY SILICON VALLEY IN
SUPPORT. DEVON ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
FILL THE INSULATION ON BEHALF
OF CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
IT'S CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL GOT
IN CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION ALSO HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THEIR
OPPOSITION YOU CAN. HI GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS AS AMENDED JULY
ELEVENTH TWENTY NINETEEN CA ARE
DOES HAVE AN OPPOSE LIST
AMENDED POSITION ON THE BILL
HOWEVER AFTER FIVE MONTHS OF
NEGOTIATIONS WE HAVE REACHED A
CONSENSUS ON LANGUAGE WITH THE
AUTHOR AND WITH THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL THAT AMENDMENT
LANGUAGE IN PARTY'S NOTED IN
THE ANALYSIS. AND WHEN THAT
AMEND LANGUAGES IN PRINCE YOUR
WILL REMOVE ITS OPPOSITION TO
THE MEASURE HOWEVER IS THE BILL
NOW CURRENTLY STANDS WE DO HAVE
AN OPPOSE UNLESS MENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING NO VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU. TWO GERMAN MAP. THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE RUN
KINKS IN REPRESENTING THREE
REGIONAL APARTMENT ASSOCIATIONS
ORANGE COUNTY EAST BAY. RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION AND
APARTMENT SITUATION CALIFORNIA
SOUTHERN CITIES. WE WANT TO
FOCUS ON THE PHYSICAL ASPECT.
THERE ARE TWO SECTIONS OF THE
BILL THE FIRST SECTION DEALS
WITH CREATING A STATEWIDE JUST
BECAUSE- PROPOSAL FOR ALL THOSE
COMMUNITIES. THAT DON'T HAVE
RENT CONTROL TODAY THAT'S
ROUGHLY. FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ONE. COMMUNITIES THAT
DON'T HAVE IT. THIS WILL FORCE
A LOT OF TIMES WORD THAT
DISPUTES ARE SETTLED EASILY
TODAY. IN THE COURT IT WILL
INCREASE. AT THE WILL BE
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASES IN COURT
FILINGS. YEAH AND FOR THAT PART
OF IT WE OPPOSE ON THE RENT
CONTROL PROVISIONS. SIMILARLY
IT WILL INCREASE THE DISPUTES.
TODAY LOCAL COMMUNITIES THAT
DON'T VIEW THAT THEY NEED RENT
CONTROL DON'T WANT IT. THIS
BILL CREATES A MANDATE ON ALL
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. CONSEQUENTLY
WE ASK YOU TO OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU. MORNING DAVID JEVER
FROM DID YOU EVER PROPERTIES
AND RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS AND
MANAGERS OF CENTRAL VALLEY.
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL OF AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THIS BILL
IS COVERING TO SPECIFIC TOPICS
AND BEING THE FACT THAT THERE
IS SOME SERIOUS CONSTITUTIONAL
ISSUES IN REGARDS OF. CAPPING
RAINS SENDING PRICES. AND THE
OTHER IN REGARDS OF THE JUST
CAUSE OF ACTION I THINK THAT
THIS BILL OUGHT TO BE REMOVED
AND PROBABLY LOOKED AT AND
ANOTHER SESSION AT ANOTHER TIME
UNTIL WE HAVE MORE TIME TO.
LOOK AT BOTH THOSE SUPPORTING
OPPOSITION SO WE COME TOGETHER
IN A BETTER SOLUTION. TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL. FINE IS YOU DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL
WHAT WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
BILL DOES NOT APPEAR TO HAVE
ANY NEAR TERM DIRECT COSTS TO
THE STATE WE WOULD NOT HOWEVER
THE WHILE THE BILL IS TO REMAIN
IN EFFECT UNTIL JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. LONG TERM
RENTAL CAPS COULD LEAD TO
VARIOUS IMPACTS ON STATE AND
LOCAL TAX REVENUES. SEE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO ABOUT A
SUSPENSE. MOVING TO. MISS SMITH
AB FIFTEEN OH SEVEN ON CHARTER
SCHOOLS THEIR SUPPORT. THE LARA
STRAND FLOOR AS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH ASK OF ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN
SUPPORT. DAVID NEVIN WITH SANTA
ANA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. IS THERE OPPOSITION.
JEFF RICE WITH THE A PLUS
PERSONALIZED LEARNING NETWORK
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED.
ALICE KESSLER BEHALF FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
AN OPPOSE POSITION BUT
UNDERSTAND THERE FURTHER
AMENDMENTS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THOSE
SEE IF THEY ADDRESS OUR
REMAINING CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THIS FINANCE HAVE A FILE FILE.
ALL RIGHT SINGLE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION MAYBE FIFTEEN
OH SEVEN WITHOUT A SUSPENSE AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE BONTA ON
FIREARM GUN SHOWS IS THERE
SUPPORT. IS THERE OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
CAPULETS REPRESENTING THE
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION WE WORK TO THIS YEAR
ON THE BUDGET AUGMENTATION
WHICH SHIFTED A LOT OF THE
MONEY FROM THE DEALER RECORD OF
SALE TO THE GENERAL FUND WE
VERY MUCH SUPPORT THAT FOR THE
ARM PROHIBITED PERSONS UP
PROGRAM SINCE THOSE ARE FOLKS
THAT ARE IN AN UNLICENSED A
INABILITY TO KERRY CATEGORY WE
ALSO WOULD NOTE THAT THE GUN
SHOW PROVISIONS THAT EXISTING
LAW TAKES CARE OF THAT SHOWS
HAPPEN RATE BY THE SAME.
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS AS A
STOREFRONT DEALERS SO THIS IS
UNNECESSARY WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
WE THINK THAT THE DEALER RECORD
OF SALE IS GETTING OUT OF REACH
FOR THE NORMAL PERSON TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM AND IT IT
WOULD VIOLATE THEIR SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR BUT NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION ALSO HERE FOR
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION GUNNERS THE
CALIFORNIA. IN OPPOSITION UP
THIS BILL CREATES A NEW TAX ON
GUN OWNERS TO FUND A BROAD
ARRAY OF DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
FIREARM ACTIVITIES. CURRENTLY
THE COST FOR NEW GUN OWNERS
AROUND FIFTY DOLLARS AND THIS
IS GOING TO UP THAT BETWEEN THE
NINETEEN CURRENT NINETEEN
DOLLAR DROZD EITHER ONE DOLLAR
FIREARM SAFETY ACT THE FIVE
DOLLAR FIREARM SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT THE IN THE TWENTY
FIVE DOLLAR. A FIREARM SAFETY
CERTIFICATE WHILE THIS DOES
LOWER THAT NINETEEN DOLLAR FEE
CURRENTLY FOR BACKGROUND CHECKS
DOWN TO ONE DOLLAR IN LIMITS
ITS APPLICATION CREATES A NEW
FEE THAT'S THIRTY ONE NINETEEN.
IT SHOULD BE NOTICED THE THAT
NOTED THAT EVEN THOUGH THE
NINETEEN DOLLAR FEE ARTS
FOURTEEN IN STATUTE IS GETTING
LOWER DOWN ONE DOLLAR UNDER
TWENTY EIGHT TWO FIVE FIVE IT'S
NOT ADDRESSED IN TWENTY TO
THIRTY WORDS STILL COULD BE
CHART I THINK THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING. THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT CAN YOU SHOULD LOOK AT
WHETHER THE FEES ACTUALLY IN
THE STATE SAME JUST GONNA AT
THAT NEW THIRTY ONE DOLLAR
FIFTEEN CENT FEE. BUT THE DEAL
MACINNES TOLD COUNT NEEDS TO BE
LOOKED AT CAREFULLY THE DRESS
ACCOUNT SO MASSED TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS SO MUCH
THAT A TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR LOAN WAS GIVEN TO THE
APPS PROGRAM A FEW YEARS AGO.
RIGHT NOW GROSS IS STRUCTURALLY
UNBALANCED AND THIS THISIS
DESPITE A FIREARM SALES BEING
DOUBLE WHAT THEY WERE WE'RE
AMASSING TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN FACT A DOUBLE FOR
THE LAST SEVEN YEARS WHAT THEY
WERE WHEN WE ARE MASSING. THE
SURPLUS. FURTHER THIS. THIS IS
SUBJECT ONGOING LITIGATION IT'S
GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE SUBJECT
ON DOING LITIGATION AND-
THERE'S COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT WITHOUT PROPOSITION THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
SMITH ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION SPORTSMAN
WOMEN'S ORGANIZATION IT'S BEEN
MENTIONED SEVERAL TIMES HERE
COMMITTEE THIS MORNING WITH AB
SEVEN NINETEEN AND AGAIN WITH
A. B. ELEVEN ELEVEN. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
HAS A STRUCTURAL AND SYSTEMIC
BUDGET DEFICIT AND IN PART
THAT'S BECAUSE FEWER PEOPLE ARE
BUYING HUNTING AND ANGLING
LICENSES. THE NORTH AMERICAN
MODEL OF CONSERVATION IS
FALLING APART WE REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT BILLS LIKE
THIS. THAT PRESENT OBSTACLES TO
LAW ABIDING CITIZENS WHO WANT
TO BE HUNTERS AND ANGLERS IF
YOU WANT TO GET A HUNTING
SPORTING LICENSE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA GOT TO TAKE A TEN
HOUR GUN SAFETY CLASS. YOU GOT
TO PROVE YOUR RESPONSIBILITY
THAT'S RIGHT ALL. FISCAL WERE
DRIVING PEOPLE AWAY FROM
GENERATING LICENSE REVENUE THAT
IS IMPORTANT TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH WILDLIFE AGAIN THEY
HAVE A STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE IT
WAS NOTED SEVERAL TIMES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT SIR
FILE. YES THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES THEA NET TO
APPROXIMATE REVENUE INCREASED
DUE TO THE FEE CHANGES IS
FIFTEEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY I WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY NINETEEN INCLUDES ELEVEN
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ON GOING TO
ADDRESS THE INSOLVENCY OF THE
DRAW SPECIAL ACCOUNT. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. AB EIGHTEEN OH NINE
BY SURVIVE TASTES DISABLED
VETERANS BUSINESS ENTERPRISES
THEIR SUPPORT. SIR OPPOSITION
IS THERE FILE YES WE'RE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT WILL
RESULT IN ON BUDGET AND ON
GOING GENERAL FUND COSTS A AS
WELL AS UNKNOWN BUT INCREASED
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
INCREASING THE MAXIMUM VALUE OF
CONTRACTS CAN BE AWARDED USING
THE DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE PROCUREMENT PROCESS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB EIGHTEEN OH NINE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. OUR FINAL
BILL AB EIGHTEEN TEN IS A
TRANSPORTATION OMNIBUS BILL BY.
MR FRAZIER IS THERE SUPPORT SIR
OPPOSITION SIR FILE YES WERE
NEUTRAL IN THIS MEASURE. SEEING
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB EIGHTEEN TEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. THAT IS THE COMPLETE
FILE WE HAVE ONE BILL ON CALL
WHICH IS AB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT.
THE WORLD GIVE MISTER BRADFORD
SIX MINUTES THE REST OF YOU.
HAVE A GOOD DAY WE'LL SEE ON
THE FLOOR. I'LL WAIT TILL
ELEVEN THIRTY
. ALL
. YOU TO OPEN
THE ROLE ONE MORE TIME PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON AB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR BATES.
BRADFORD. FOR THE FINAL VOTE IS
FOUR TO ONE WE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND WE WILL ADJOURN THE
MEETING